foreign
Courtney joins us up next in Jackson
Tennessee Courtney welcome to the Ramsay
show
get my call sure how can we help today
so I'm like super upside down on my car
and I am in babysit number two and it's
actually my highest debt but it's just
it's causing me so much trouble not the
vehicle but the payment itself is just
outrageous so I'm trying to figure out
what to do as far as you know my vehicle
goes how much do you owe on the car
um I owe about 32 000. okay and what is
it worth right now
eighteen thousand oh
how how did it get to this point what'd
you buy the car for
um after interest and stuff it was forty
nine thousand dollars
so you paid 49 for it what was it worth
at the time you bought it you think it
was worth 49
um I don't remember I want to say it was
like 35 or so and
um the interest is I think is an
interest is what's like got it all
messed up what's your payment and what's
your interest rate
I pay 688 a month uh yeah it's rough
industry is 12 point I'm sorry 15.12
percent
why did you get such a terrible interest
rate
honestly I'm not sure because this was
the first vehicle I ever financed
and before like after that I got other
debt but before the car I had like three
thousand dollars in student loans and
that was like all that was on my credit
oh my goodness what's the what's the
term for this how long
is the loan for six years six years what
kind of car is it
a 2018 Volkswagen Tiguan okay how long
have you had it
eight months and that's how like deep
how low the value is gone in eight
months
it's gone down that quickly or do you
think you bought it a little too too
high priced maybe I bought it you know
but I was just thinking wow you know
decrease in value I guess we sold this
car
the dealership I worked for no oh yeah
was it like a A co-worker that's a
friend or or how did that happen
yeah it is a friend but I don't work in
the sales department I work in the
service department but yeah it was a
friend and I don't I'm not sure like you
know have you talked to them about this
I have
um what did they say and I think that
pretty much they're telling me like at
the time like the market was just so
messed up on cars
have you had any like Frank
conversations with them like asking kind
of like what was the value of the car
when you sold it to me
I haven't but that is a good idea I'm
actually on my lunch break right now so
I could do that when I come back here
there's no way that car was worth 49.5
when you bought it which is how much
you're paying with all these payments
and actually it was like 55 after I put
the I got I did get all the warranties
and things on it but how long have you
worked you can return that warranty
right and get some money back out of
this
yeah I could return the warranty how
much would that give you back
um probably about maybe 5 000 okay and
how much money do you have in the bank
um I have about 2 000 in my checking
account and other than that I just have
a thousand dollars for an emergency fund
okay
how long have you worked for this
dealership
about a year now
do you feel like in general they
typically have pretty good integrity
emotion time yeah yeah and and the my
co-worker he's actually a friend of mine
and
you know
my friends don't screw me over at 15
interest that's what I was thinking too
is like I feel like I've been screwed
over on it and you know financially
that's that's a big I want to know how
much this guy made off this deal
yeah probably a lot and you know I'm 22
so I'm not trying to be stuck in this
for seven years
was it we had said that 18 000 value
that you say your car has like is that
from Kelley Blue Book is that somebody
your job that said that
KBB is that private party or trade-in
yes that's private party
okay I'm gonna still do some more
homework and research every single place
that buys used cars and that's online
that's local dealerships to see how much
you could get for this maybe even try
listing it and see if you can get more
for it
and I okay this this may not be the best
advice but if I'm in your shoes
talking to my boss and I'm saying here's
the situation how is this car that I
just bought eight months ago for this
price now worth 18 and kind of walk
through the situation with your
co-worker because my hope is that Azure
employer there's some sliver of heart
there that maybe they'll even consider
buying it back from you at a higher rate
right closer to what you paid for it
right
yeah there's going to be stupid tax on
this either way the only other option
here to get out from under this thing uh
soon is if you went to your local credit
union and get a personal loan for 14 000
to cover the difference
right and now you're 14 000 in debt
instead of thirty two thousand in debt
at a much lower interest rate
and I have other debt but it's just it's
7 800 and
that off pretty quick
but I'm thinking long term like oh well
it's going to take me years to get out
that with this car where's the where'd
the 78 come from because I thought you
said you only had 3 000 in debt when you
got the car well I have three thousand
at the time and this was a stupid
decision but after I got this car I
started started getting all these um
uh things in the mail like oh you're
approved today for this and that and
this and that and at the time I was just
like Oh yay extra money and I took out
personal loans but I've never done that
again I've learned my lesson because the
interest rates on them are outrageous
and I actually
um had like a two thousand dollar loan
that ended up being like forty five
hundred dollars
overall so
well I I'm assuming that you've had your
I've had it moment that you're done with
today yes I've had it I'm I'm too young
to be stressed about this I've got goals
and I'm like no I'm trying to get out of
all this while I can heck yeah well
start ripping up your mail and if it
says zero percent or if it looks like
free money run as far as you can because
there's no such thing as a free lunch
yeah there is no free money I thought I
learned that the hard way they are not
your friend
and by the way this dealership is not
yeah I I've thought about that what are
you making at this dealership
I make about 50 000 a year okay
do you have any credit cards right now
I don't I actually paid that was my
number one baby steps or in the baby
step number two the first thing I did
was pay off a credit card I owed like
288 on it I paid it I called I canceled
and I I'm out of the credit card
situation okay so this 50 000 is that
your only job you've got one job right
now I do only have one job I've been
searching I've been listening to y'all
and a lot of people are talking about
like doordash and I've been considering
doing like a part-time tour Dash talk
just something to get a little more
money to try to pay it all faster yeah
you can also look into grocery delivery
services like instacart or shipped
um you can even try Amazon Flex if
that's in your area to deliver packages
on your own schedule and you can make
some good money doing that
yeah and right now with where you're at
I know you're mad that like you're in
this situation at 22 years old like you
said you've got goals you need to get
out of this so I want you to take that
anger that you feel and that frustration
and just Channel all of it into doing
everything you can to get rid of the
stat I want you working 60 80 hours a
week I want you cutting back to the bare
minimum eating you know as cheaply as
possible like we have got to go scorched
Earth on this
yeah for sure and I have been I've got
the app that you guys uh talk about and
I've been budgeting it's just like I was
just trying to think about the long run
and what I could do about my car we'll
see if if you can talk to the dealership
and go Hey listen you guys screwed me on
this deal and I work here and that is
not cool to treat an employee that way
so here's what I'm asking trade in this
car give me the crappiest car on your
lot to get me out of this situation and
if you still need to go take a small
personal loan from that credit union to
cover this mess and get out of this
thing then do that and then we're
attacking the rest of the debt while
driving this beater car until it's all
done
yeah I'll do that I'm down to drive a
beater car whatever it takes to get out
of you know and stand up for yourself
Courtney don't take crap from these guys
and I'd be leaving this dealership as
soon as I'm out of this mess because I
don't trust these people